c'est le début de la pêche au homard
d'automne en nouvelle écosse la plus
grande saison des maritimes est aussi la
plus lucrative
tout le monde dit la mairie de nice
d'entre nous vont désormais la grande
majorité de son homard en chine et en
corée
l'asie pour mon réveil dans l'asie et
l'appétit asiatiques pour le homard
canadien semble insatiable en 2018
seulement les exportations vers la chine
ont augmenté de 50% mais les asiatiques
ne se contente plus d'acheter seulement
le homard ils veulent aujourd'hui
contrôler la ressource de la mer à
l'assiette
nous sommes dans un petit village côtier
de la baie de fundy au nouveau brunswick
ici principal acheteur
c'est le chinois ni tanks j'ai un accès
direct au homard ni thang a acheté il ya
trois ans un vieux vivier abandonné
qu'il a aujourd'hui remplacées par des
installations flambant neuf en chine le
marché vient juste d'ouvrir beaucoup de
chinois aiment le homard vivant le
canada interdit aux investisseurs
étrangers d'acquérir des permis de pêche
cependant ils peuvent acheter des usines
de transformation ce qui leur permet
d'accéder à la ressource
c'est exactement ce qu'a fait nico il
n'est pas seul à faire des acquisitions
dans la région au cours des cinq
dernières années au moins une vingtaine
d' usine de homards ont été achetés ou
construites par des investisseurs
extérieurs dont randonnée est ce qu'on
va vraiment perdre le contrôle de notre
industrie c'est une question maintenant
je pense que l'on doit opposer ce
spécialiste empêche crack désormais les
décisions soient prises en dehors de la
région
cet argent là et pas nécessairement
toujours réinvesti dans la communauté
t'as pas la même attachement à la
communauté que que nous on peut avoir
par exemple comme des gens
las mais certains propriétaires comme
des listes d'entremont continue de
résister à l'envahisseur étranger
l'industrie des pêches est encore le
poumon économique d'une très grande
majorité de villages côtiers acadiens un
patrimoine qui pourrait être menacée si
des monopoles étrangers venaient à se
former des nouveaux acheteurs qui
pourraient non seulement étouffer les
entreprises locales mais aussi dicter
les prix aux pêcheurs ici nicollin
steinbach radio-canada à publico ouest
le bas en nouvelle écosse